أريد نعم ، أريد استخدام
المتكلم في الثواني القليلة الماضية لإعطاء بعض
النصائح لأه لخلفي الذي قد يكون هو
أو هي
رقم واحد ، ابق قريبًا من
الأمريكيين التمسك بالأوكرانيين
متمسكين بالحرية والديمقراطية في
كل مكان خفض الضرائب  وتحرير التنظيم
أينما كان يمكنك جعل هذا
المكان أعظم مكان للعيش والاستثمار فيه
، وقد
ساعدنا ذلك في
اجتياز هذا البلد للوباء والمساعدة في إنقاذ
بلد آخر من الهمجية
وبصراحة هذا يكفي لمواصلة
المهمة  أنجزت إلى حد كبير
في الوقت الحالي ،
أود أن أشكرك السيد المتحدث ، وأريد أن
أشكر جميع الموظفين الرائعين في
House of commons ، وأريد أن أشكر جميع
أصدقائي وزملائي ، وأريد أن أشكر
صديقي القديم آه المقابل والسيد المتحدث ،
أريد أن أشكر الجميع  هنا
وهاستا لا فيستا
حبيبي شكرا لك
مرحبا